hey youtubers it's Charlie since arrow
is on break this week I decided to do
some fun bonus predictions for the end
of the season or at least the rest of
the season since we've seen a lot of
behind the scenes pictures and there's
been a lot of comments about what's
going on in episode descriptions there
are gonna be five big questions that I'm
gonna ask and try to answer in this
video so I'm gonna save a lot of the
season 3 talk for a separate video so
this is just gonna be about what's
happening for the rest of season 2 if
you're finding me for the first time I
typically do arrow videos every week
usually Wednesdays and Thursdays are
kind of like my unofficial DC days and
whenever there are new episodes I always
do bonus Q&A videos be sure to subscribe
to get everything
next week is actually gonna be a really
cool crossover with the flash so here
are my top 5 arrow questions for the
rest of the season I'm gonna answer
these but obviously feel free to write
in your own opinions as we go along so
here we go
number 5 what is Slade going to do with
his Super Soldier army not just this
season what's he gonna do with it once
they're done I think the Army is just a
means to an end the end of Oliver that
is Slade is trying to tear down Oliver's
life and of all the relationships in his
life you know his family his friends one
of his biggest is with the city itself
with Starling city Slade could have
totally killed Oliver all by himself he
doesn't need brother blood or Summer
Glau who I'm just calling ravager right
now because he's all about making Oliver
suffer he needs to make the city suffer
so he's just gonna blow up a big part of
it and then kill a bunch of people
basically turned the city into something
you'd see in like a Grand Theft Auto
game but if he's successful what's he
gonna do with the army once he's done
he's not trying to make a new League of
Assassins you know he's not trying to
create a new evil organization I think
he just intends to walk away he's a
loner you know as we saw in episode 18
he doesn't really care about brother
blood either so he's just gonna
disappear when it's all done there's
also the chance that he'll destroy the
army himself they're all convicts so the
arrangement he made with them seems very
temporary like he doesn't care if any of
them survive after he's done with Oliver
that's all he really cares about is the
Oliver part not the super soldier part
number 4 what is Laurel going to do now
that she knows Oliver is the arrow the
producers made this really offhanded
comment that audiences are expecting her
to freak out but will be surprised
whenever we see what her actual response
is I think that just means that Laurel
will
totally be down with it she did see a
little bit of action during
birds-of-prey and in the description for
episode 21 city of blood it says that
she's on the hunt for Sebastian again
ever since they started showing her with
Sebastian way earlier this season I
thought that she might be the one to end
up taking him down
it's like you have Oliver versus Slade
and over on one side you have Laurel
versus brother blood and now that
Ravager is the villain I'm actually
wondering if Sara is gonna be the one to
take her on directly or if they'll let
Felicity do the honors there is all this
Laurel Black Canary talk but I still
think it's way too soon for her to
become Black Canary so I think they're
gonna say that for season three or even
season four I'm really hoping that Sara
survives which actually brings me to
number three who is going to die this
season we should also ask is anyone
gonna die personally I think so I just
feel like the show has been escalating
things so much eventually the only way
to top it all will be to kill a major
character it could totally be a
supporting character like Moira but
think about it this way any characters
that are either currently or will become
superheroes are probably safe so here's
something really important though that
kind of ties into all this reportedly
there was a funeral scene that was shot
during episode 21 so if someone is gonna
die this season it probably is going to
happen in that episode side note though
I will be super bummed if it all turns
out to be misdirection like it's a fake
funeral or a funeral for a character
that we didn't really see a lot but
here's something else that's really
important and hopefully it will make you
feel a little bit better
Caity Lotz was actually listed on the
call sheet for episode 22 Streets of
Fire so Sara will still be alive then
meaning she's not gonna die
I actually cheered a little bit when I
saw this so if she's gonna survive to
season three that means that Laurel is
definitely not going to become the Black
Canary this season it also means they
can do more birds of prey because
Huntress has to get out of jail sometime
and I'm hoping it's because Amanda
Waller recruits her into the Suicide
Squad Suicide Squad birds-of-prey
crossover it would be amazing
on to number two will Ivo turn out to be
Felicity's father and are we gonna find
out who her father is we still haven't
seen the rest of what happens on the
island before Oliver took Slade's eye
out you know Ivo is still alive and
there's so many things that line up with
what Felicity has said about her father
and what AIBO has said about himself and
all those flashback scenes Andrew
Kreisberg
actually said that we will
more about Felicity this season but they
are holding a lot of really big stuff
for season three meaning that whoever
her father is it's actually pretty
important if her father were someone
normal they would just straight-up tell
us there wouldn't be any reason to keep
it a secret so even if her father is not
Ivo he's still someone very important in
the DC Universe that doesn't mean that
he is necessarily evil
but it does mean the show isn't going to
tell us outright who he is this season
so for now let's just stick with Ivo
until we get more details but it's
always possible that her father could be
connected to hi for whoever the big bat
is in season 3 so it's really exciting
so here we go here's my number one arrow
question for the rest of the season how
is Oliver going to defeat Slade
we've only got FSO descriptions up to 21
city of blood and that's it in that
episode
Oliver tries to just flat-out surrender
to Slade but it sounds like team arrow
is gonna lock him up so he can't and I
also I don't think Slade would stop his
plans just because Oliver surrendered he
wants to make him suffer so here a
couple possible solutions one Oliver
could just flat-out find a way to
overpower him in mortally wound him he's
almost invincible remember in episode 18
Slade talked about how the mirakuru
healed his body after he got ripped to
shreds so he is not gonna be able to
kill him without chopping his head off
and I don't think he's gonna do that
he's not a killer that's like the whole
arc of his character this season Oliver
does not kill people anymore to be fair
though Oliver did kill someone this
season remember when count vertigo tried
to dose Felicity with the vertigo drug
he shot him out of window so he's pretty
dead but the second option actually
involves a bigger threat coming along
like Rachael Ghul you know something
that would force Slade to stop attacking
Oliver for a minute and make him
redirect all that evil shadow energy
into the League of Assassins Manu
Bennett kind of teased this but the
producer said that there were some
special things they were working on for
the finale you know a lot characters
that might end up happening but
completely dependent on a bunch of stuff
behind the scenes working out I think
that they were just talking about
wanting to do raesha al Ghul and Warner
Brothers you know having to okay it from
a legal perspective remember it actually
took them a long time to get the okay
the official okay to do Barry Allen in
episode 8 & 9 so it's possible that
they'll do ratio goal and it's just
taken this long for them to get
clearance if that ends up happening it
would totally mean that Slade and Oliver
could temporarily at least
fire and be brothers again so to speak
while they try to fend off the League of
Assassins that would actually be pretty
badass but it doesn't address the issue
of evil Tinkerbell shadow you know I
don't think Oliver is gonna take the
mirakuru out of Slade's body but I do
think the team arrow will find a way to
get rid of that evil shadow or at least
clear Slade's head the show isn't gonna
kill off Slade like he's not gonna die
they didn't even kill Merlin after
season 1 they're just too awesome to
completely get rid of plus John
Barrowman was on set for the finale so
Merlyn will definitely play a role in
whatever that final outcome is but now
it's your turn how do you think they're
gonna fix Slade in the finale and who do
you think is gonna die this season you
know it's gonna be Moira or is it gonna
be some other side character also
because there was no new episode of air
I'm not gonna do a Q&A this week but I
will be answering questions in the
comments next week also is the really
awesome flash crossover episode so it's
gonna be really cool be sure to
subscribe to get my video and in the
meantime you can actually click here to
learn all about the new team Deathstroke
it's gonna be so badass it's like the
evil Trinity and you can click here to
learn all about Captain America 3 thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow
high fives
you